el salvador a country of six and a half
million people has started to adopt
bitcoin they've made it legal tender
they've built a network of atms they've
created a mobile app and they've paid
some of their citizens to go ahead and
start using bitcoin they also are in the
process of issuing bitcoin-backed bonds
and they're even building a place called
bitcoin city and now el salvador the
small but mighty central american
country they're getting a lot of
questions the imf doesn't seem to like
their plans and now there's a bipartisan
bill that is being floated in the united
states that is taking a look at what's
going on in el salvador the bill being
introduced is being called the
accountability for cryptocurrency in el
salvador act and what it is going to do
is it's going to do an analysis of el
salvador's adoption of bitcoin as legal
tender the risks for cyber security
economic stability and democratic
governance and also it's asking for a
plan to mitigate potential risks to the
u.s financial system now we have a quote
right here from the senator from idaho
james rich and what he said was el
salvador's adoption of bitcoin as legal
tender raises significant concerns about
the economic stability and financial
integrity of a vulnerable u.s trading
partner in central america this new
policy has the potential to weaken u.s
sanctions policy empowering malign
actors like china and organized criminal
organizations then he finished by saying
our bipartisan legislation seeks greater
clarity on el salvador's policy and
requires the administration to mitigate
potential risk to the u.s financial
system now this is absolutely insane
what the hell does the united states
care what else salvador is doing there's
six and a half million citizens they're
a sovereign nation they don't even have
their own currency they simply are
trying to find more superior technology
to adopt to make a better life more
financial security and more economic
opportunity for those six and a half
million people if we go and we look at
what president buchelli of el salvador
thinks about this well you guessed it
never in his wildest dreams did he think
that the u.s government would be afraid
of what they are doing in el salvador
and so if we then start to think about
what people across the internet also
thought when they see something that
says that they plan to mitigate risk to
the united states financial system posed
by adoption of cryptocurrency as legal
tender in certain countries well we've
got this right here from sophia zeller
in which she states can't get over the
irony of this bill which targets el
salvador for embracing bitcoin being
framed as an accountability measure the
fed has never been audited bitcoin is
completely open there's millions of
people who audit it every day and the
u.s has a history of weaponizing dollars
reserve currency status with impunity
ladies and gentlemen make sure you're
paying attention the world is shifting
right before our eyes the united states
is now trying to figure out what is
their strategy the president put forward
an executive order he wants the u.s to
be a leader in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies el salvador already has
the lead they're moving their country
onto the bitcoin standard rather than
try to attack them rather than try to
use regulation to slow them down the
united states needs to get in the game
we can compete on the global stage let's
get to the front of the line but let's
do it by being competitors not by
complaining hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time